DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
I'm Dustin Kirkland.
I'm here with David Aronchick,
product manager for Kubeflow
at Google.
And I'm really interested
in your insight
into the Kubeflow project.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
It has been an
incredibly wild ride.
I first came to Kubernetes
two and 1/2 years ago.
I was, I like to say, the first
non-founding product manager
of Kubernetes.
And I managed the platform
for two and 1/2 years.
And I was lucky enough to see
all the growth and evolution
of the Kubernetes ecosystem.
After that time, I went
and took a step back
and said, well, geez, what's
the next hard problem here?
And it really is
not Kubernetes--
not that there's not an enormous
amount to do in the core
Kubernetes platform--
but it's really,
how do we empower
the next level of
people on top of it
using all the elements in the
platform that we built out?
I went out and talked
to customers, and users,
and data scientists.
And they all said,
"We would love
to do what you're doing with
Kubernetes but with ML and AI.
And so that really was,
how do we make it portable?
How do we make it composable?
How do we make it declarative?
In the same way that you can do
with Kubernetes applications,
you can do with this
very complex stack.
And so we brought
it together and made
our initial announcement
in December.
And we're very proud to have
announced our 0.1 release.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Was that
in the keynote this morning?
DAVID ARONCHICK: At the
keynote this morning, exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
what are the highlights
of the keynote this morning,
if you can recap for us here?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
So as I mentioned, we had our
first official 0.1 release.
That's a cut release,
meaning we do all the testing
and have zero outstanding P0, P1
bugs, and all that good stuff,
helping things get to
really production ready.
We announced all the partners
and contributors who've
been adding to the platform.
We have over 15
major corporations
who are contributing
to the core platform,
700 commits in the
past three months.
We're really really
excited with the momentum.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Do you want to
spotlight a few of those here?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Sure.
Red Hat has it
running on OpenShift.
Weave Works has contributed
monitoring to it.
DaoCloud in China has done
not just contributions
to the overall
TensorFlow framework,
but done a number of
different meetups,
and really expanded our presence
in that market and region.
And on and on and on.
Ubuntu just launched
with 1804 native support
for ML and Kubeflow.
So we're really really excited
with all the contributors
so far.
And then, finally, the
real end of the day
is, it's now an order
of minutes in order
to get an entire complicated,
distributed ML workload up
and running.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
On any Kubernetes.
DAVID ARONCHICK: On any
Kubernetes-compliant platform.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
conformant Kubernetes.
So if you've got a
conformant Kubernetes,
you can deploy Kubeflow
on top of that.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And as
simple as a Kubectl command?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Exactly.
Even better than that, actually.
Though we, obviously, only use
native Kubernetes components,
we actually detail
using ksonnet.
There's another contributor--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Oh, there you go.
DAVID ARONCHICK: --from
Heptio, helping us use ksonnet
for our application deployment.
You literally list in code
the declarative framework
that you want to
get out the door.
So let's say I want to use
components 1, 7, and 8.
You declare that in code.
You can check that code into
Git, just like anything else,
and use that as your
deployment framework, --
and Kubernetes does the rest.
So no more pip install
A, pip install B,
I forgot this
dependency isn't there--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: --and good
luck reproducing that, right?
DAVID ARONCHICK: And
good luck reproducing it.
All that is built
into the system.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, that's great.
So it's really
changing the investment
that a given data
scientist has to put down
to start doing the work that's
actually interesting to them,
which is the machine
learning algorithms, right?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
And while there's plenty
of opportunity to get
started on a day 0
where you click a button
and it spins up a hosted
Jupyter Notebook or something
like that--
which is certainly fine if
you just want to mess around--
what we find is that,
more often than not,
these data scientists who want
to get that great first start
experience then end up
having to rewrite everything
to make it production-ready
and bring it from your laptop
or bring it from cloud
one to cloud two.
Kubeflow runs great everyone.
It runs on your laptop.
It runs on your
training rig, on-prem.
It runs on cloud one.
It runs on cloud two.
Anywhere there's a Kubernetes
conformant configuration--
cluster, excuse me--
it'll run great.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And do you
have any sample workloads
that can be deployed,
today, into Kubeflow as--
kind of getting started?
DAVID ARONCHICK:
Yeah, absolutely.
We have a great examples
directory where people
are already contributing.
As those of you that
saw the keynote saw,
we demonstrated the
tensor-to-tensor framework
model that runs inside
Kubeflow right now.
And that did raw
sentiment analysis, which
is an extremely common problem.
People want to measure
inbound emails,
figure out how mad people
are, look at Twitter streams,
look at comments, and be
able to judge what's good
and what's bad and
what needs surfacing.
So that model is all built
in, and it runs great.
It runs on your laptop.
It runs on a GPU.
It runs on TPUs, as
you saw on the stage.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Gotcha.
Can I run Not Hotdog from
HBO's "Silicon Valley"?
Tim Anglade's--
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
Actually, as part of
the tensor-to-tensor,
there is image
detection built in.
But we also support
ResNet, ImageNet, and a lot
of the other common frameworks.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
So you're really bringing AIML
to a cloud-native discipline.
I'm actually really
impressed with this.
I think this is a really
important step forward
into letting data scientists
worry about the problems
that they worry about, and
IT administrators and app
developers handle their own.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah,
I couldn't agree more.
More than anything,
Kubernetes has been about,
how do we break
apart the things that
are tightly merged together?
Because that just helps
people move much faster.
And then your IT pros can
focus on what they do great,
and your software engineers can
and your data
scientists can focus on
and what they do great.
And all of them together
can empower all the people
in the world to make great
decisions about where they need
to move resources around, what
people are being under-served
by services, and
so on and so forth.
The more that we can break
those things apart and advance
each of those disciplines,
I think the better off
the platform is.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: From a
Kubernetes perspective,
do you think we can
lead here by helping
use ML from the
exhaust that comes out
of a Kubernetes cluster,
the logs and monitoring?
Can we actually
ingest that and start
developing some predictive
analytics for Kubernetes
itself?
Is this an opportunity
to reinforce
what we're doing here?
DAVID ARONCHICK:
Yeah, absolutely.
So just like Kubernetes was an
externalization of the things
that we had done at
Google for 10, 15 years,
Kubeflow is very much
an externalization
of some of the pipelines
and other stacks
that we have internally that
we use at Google for ML.
We're not even close
to the end here,
as those that saw the
TensorFlow DevSummit saw.
There's a great platform
effort around what's
called TFX, TensorFlow
Extended, which will
appear in Kubeflow over time.
But directly to the
answer to your question--
internally to Google,
we do that all the time.
We look at our version
of Kubernetes, Borg,
and we use ML to study
jobs and see what's working
and what's not and all
that kind of stuff.
Using that same kind of
anonymoly-- excuse me,
anomaly detection
as part of Kubeflow
is definitely a core mission.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
That's great.
Since you are ultimately
a user of Kubernetes--
I mean, you're
running a project that
sits on top of Kubernetes--
surely you've got some hope,
some wishes, some plans
for Kubernetes itself.
Can you share back with us
where some of the big problems
are left to solve in Kubernetes?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
You know, I've seen it grow so
much over the past three years.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Sure.
Given your past as
well, you are the person
to ask this question to.
DAVID ARONCHICK:
Well, I will say
it's difficult to overstate the
amount of traction and distance
they've gotten in these
really core areas--
storage, networking,
multi-tenancy.
These are really hard problems.
And there's still miles
to go, but they've
made enormous progress.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Which of those do you
need at the heart of Kubeflow
to sort of evolve and mature?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Well.
I think more than anything,
what we'd really like
is continued investment
by each of the people
who are great at those solutions
and clean layers between them.
So you take folks
like NVIDIA, who
are contributing
around accelerators,
and you take people
like Rook, who
are contributing around
storage, and you take people
like Cisco, who are
contributing around networking.
Those people are going to
be experts at what they do.
And as long as they plug
into the clean interfaces
that Kubernetes
provides, then Kubeflow
can consume all of that
goodness without having
to know anything about
it-- without having
to know which version
of Driver is doing this,
or what private
network is doing that.
We're just going to use
what's already provided to us.
So more than anything, I'd just
love everyone who's experts--
whether or not it's a different
cloud or different hardware
system or a different
software stack that
underlies this stuff--
to continue to invest, make
it run great with Kubernetes,
and invest in the interfaces
that go on top of it.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: What
brought you to Kubernetes?
Can you tell us
just how you came
to be a product manager
on Kubernetes itself?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
So I was, at the time, working
at Chef in enterprise software.
I was a senior director of
product marketing there.
And I happen to know
Craig McLuckie, co-founder
of the Kubernetes project.
And he is a persistent dude.
So we just started
talking, and he kept
saying, "You've got to come in.
You've got to do this thing."
And I was like, wow, this
Kubernetes thing really
is starting to be something.
And I joined up shortly after.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Cool.
So Craig recruited you.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Oh, absolutely.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Awesome.
Well, speaking of Craig
and the community,
is there anyone else
in the community--
there's a ton of great people
in the community, but maybe
your opportunity to
send a thanks out
or a shout out to
someone who inspires you
in the Kubernetes community.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Boy,
there really are a ton.
When I think about
it, there's so
many people who deserve an
enormous amount of credit.
I think there are people who
are really doing a lot of great
work bridging the gap between
those who are familiar with
Kubernetes and containers,
and those who aren't--
people like Kelsey Hightower,
Jessie Frazelle, and so on.
I think there are those
who are keeping the trains
running, the unsung heroes--
Paris, Sarah Novotny, all
the community managers.
It's incredibly
difficult to overstate
how valuable that glue is.
And then there are the real--
oh geez, the people
who've been on it forever,
who still show up and pay
attention to GitHub issues
and do all the hard work--
Brian Grant, Tim
Hockin, Eric Tune.
On and on and on.
They're just absolutely
out there every day,
still answering these
questions and keeping
things architecturally pure.
I wish I could deserve
one iota of credit here.
I think if there was one
thing that everyone said,
it was how well thought
through and well-designed
the core APIs of Kubernetes are.
And that's really
been the reason
that all these things--
that we can build Kubeflow
without having to fork, because
the APIs and the core platform
is so solid.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
It's amazing how far
we've come in such a
short amount of time.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Oh, yeah.
Very, very difficult to believe.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
one last question.
As you think about
young engineers who
are university
students who are seeing
our community from the
outside and wanting
to be a part of
this, do you have
any advice for
those people and how
to get involved in Kubernetes?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
I know it will feel,
to a lot of folks,
like it is an overwhelming
amount of information
that you need to pick
up and help with,
and geez, where
do I get started?
I'll say what I've been saying
for the past three years.
There's a "help wanted" label.
Literally any one of those
"help wanted" labels,
you can go and pick up.
You can learn as well as
anyone and get started.
And whether or not that's
documentation, or fixing
an error code, or actually
fixing a unit test,
all the way up to
redesigning an interface,
the community is ready to accept
your help and get started.
And so I guess my one advice
would be diving into GitHub,
find an area where someone
is already raising their hand
and saying "I would
love some help."
And then, don't hesitate
to ask questions.
There will be someone out there
who's ready to respond and get
you going.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's right.
Well, David, thank
you for your time.
DAVID ARONCHICK: My pleasure.